I was muted.
Hello everybody, welcome to...
I forgot my bunny ears!
Set up everything else.
One second.
I forgot the most important thing!
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it, I can't believe it, I can't believe it.
I cannot believe it.
Wait, they're kinda big, aren't they?
That's a bit better.
Maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
That's a bit better.
Maybe.
Do they look even?
Thank you!
I like mates and bunny girls.
Really?
Rascal does not dream of a maid bunny girl.
Okay!
Now we're ready!
That's why I love Toki.
She is a maid, and also a bunny girl.
You're so right.
One of them looks big.
It's only when I look certain ways, one looks bigger than the other.
I fell asleep before the end of the collab last night.
But you did great for your first hell dive.
Thank you!
Hopefully the devs fixed that glitch that kept saying you were killed by an innocent kettle.
I don't know what was going on.
So crazy, right?
Thank you!
Chuu!
And drink those things with the five gifted!
Put on the bunny ears mint.
We got a bunny garden to venture to.
If you don't have bunny ears on, it scares them away, you know?
It's a fact.
It's a real fact.
Hold on, I am gonna make myself a wee bit like that.
There we go.
This is a different Bustin' than usual, huh?
Also, welcome back, Minto!
Thank you, NapNap!
What do you mean by that?
It's always the same kind of Bustin'.
Love the collab last night.
Thank you!
So...
I am a big fan of curate games.
They always just appeal to me in the best ways.
Also, can you guys see my...
My eye?
Tracker?
Can you...
Is it on?
Can you see it?
We can see it?
I tried to make it not so...
Invasive.
I tried to make it like a little bit more...
A little bit...
What's the word?
A little less obvious.
Subtle!
It's a bit hard to see.
Oh wait, actually...
I didn't want it to like...
Um...
Get too in the way, you know?
But also...
I changed the opacity on it...
When I set it up earlier...
And now I don't know how to change it.
But...
We'll see...
Yeah, it's a little less distracting.
Let's see how it is in the game.
It might be easier to see there.
Um...
Yeah, of course we can't have it get in the way of the guns.
That'd be ridiculous.
Okie dokie.
Um...
So yeah!
This game...
Like I said...
I'm a fan of Kirite games.
Um...
This one is very much like Dream City Club.
So my...
Neurons were especially...
Um...
Perked?
My neurons were especially activated.
Um...
As for the girls...
Can you see my mouse?
Yeah.
As for the girls...
I'm thinking...
The...
The side pony girl looks like...
She's catching my interest the most.
Just...
But usually I like inner color.
Um...
But she's kind of like Gyaru-esque.
So...
I'm kind of a fan.
She's sassy!
I'm like...
I mean her skirt...
Sorry I'm kind of blocking it.
Everything?
Um...
I don't know what their names are.
That's the one thing about being like a streamer.
Is...
Wanting to watch something.
But also being like...
No I can't watch it because...
I have to be the one...
Like...
I wanna have a raw reaction when I stream it.
You know?
So...
Um...
They're all good.
Short haired tomboy is peak for me.
She's very cute.
And she's got kind of like a Hime cut.
Going on a little bit.
But I like the pink...
The blonde to pink fade.
I'm a big fan of that.
Um...
Middle girl is cute.
She's just kind of...
She's kind of plain.
So it's like...
You know...
Not my type.
Exactly.
Um...
Middle girl is cute.
Middle one has default thigh highs.
Are they thigh highs?
Or are they...
Tights?
Oh wait.
Maybe...
That is a sliver...
Maybe that is a sliver of...
Thigh.
Right there.
Looks like tights to me.
No I think that's a sliver of thigh.
Right there.
Anyway...
The booba variety is lacking.
Yeah!
I mean she's definitely the biggest.
Um...
It might...
It might have been nicer maybe to get some petan girls or something.
But that's okay.
What's under extra?
I'm keep wondering.
Event CG...
This building?
It is...
Thank you!
This building I'm pretty sure is where the chubby girl maid cafe is.
There was some other ones in there.
Hmm?
Does this take place in Akiba?
I'm scanning the stream...
unsure...
Fuckiba?
Don't call it that!
Tutorial?
For what?
Event CG?
CD, album, and mystery.
Mystery!
Alright, let's start.
Let's start!
What am I doing?
Me starting this game?
I'm pretty sure.
That's so funny.
Why did I make such a big mistake?
I would never do something like that normally.
My company fired me!
The bunny maid girl in the lower left is the best IMA job?
Stop it!
I'm not even a bunny most of the time.
It is what it is.
It's not the first time it's happened.
Oh wait, sorry.
I forgot to read your thing, Rico.
I think I reacted but I forgot to read it.
Since my cat decided that he needs to be on my team, he's on my lap right now.
How are things going with the quest to get Butaro a friend?
Oh yeah, Butaro.
I got him a friend.
I
got my cat a friend!
Actually, I've been trying to like...
I've been not wanting to say so much because...
I didn't want to say anything until they were adjusted entirely.
They're still getting to know each other.
But...
Because, you know, if they were like...
If there was like something really, really wrong and they like couldn't get along at all, I wanted, you know, then I might have to like take her back and I didn't want to be like, I got a friend!
And then I have to give her back to the shelter or anything.
So...
But she's very, very sweet.
She's very, very cute.
I'll talk more about her later though.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm thankful they hired me in the first place.
I have nothing but gratitude for the company.
My boss even cried for me when they fired me.
He said, I'm sorry, I couldn't help you out.
They told me that this company wasn't the right fit for me and that there are other places where I could shine.
It was nice of them to say that.
Is there really somewhere out there?
Some place that would take in a fool like me?
Am I Hito?
Am I Hito for real?
Even if I could get another job somewhere else, I would just mess everything up for the people there.
She's got a fetish for fine art.
A pair of thigh highs.
An oversized sweatshirt.
What do you mean?
Even if I could just get...
Oh yeah.
I would mess everything up for the people there.
Maybe my life is done for.
Maybe my afterlife is done for.
I didn't even think it had started.
You want to play this too eventually so I can't watch the stream?
Oh!
Well, let me know what you think when you play it.
On a scale of 0 to Stinky House...
No, she's perfect.
She's not stinky at all.
She's so cute.
Oh my god.
Mm-hmm.
She's my little princess.
Time to drink my problems away.
Pretty sure there's a bar somewhere in this building.
I like the little open sign.
Oh wow.
We don't have that much money.
Okay.
Oh, she's actually so cute.
Wait.
I'm sorry?
Do you guys want me to read?
Um...
What she says too?
I guess it might be easier, right?
Just throwing out a guess here.
But did something bad happen to you?
That's why you're trying to drink and forget everything?
Or...
Are you trying to get me to go to your hostess club?
No, I'm not.
I just happened to see you before you came to work.
So I was curious.
You're wrong.
You just happened to catch my eye before I got to work.
Caught my eye?
She looks like a little country bumpkin.
She's got like this plaid like ascot on.
And like her jean skirt.
It's just...
You look so tired.
As if your afterlife...
Sorry.
Your life is over.
Eyes up, girl.
My eyes are up here.
I think it's a little off.
But that's okay.
You might be right.
Oh, yay!
You are...
Oh my gosh.
She's like, I knew it.
Yes.
Your life is...
Oh my gosh.
You just wanna throw yourself off Monte Bashi bridge right now.
I get it.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so...
I'm so sorry.
I'm so glad that I was right.
That you are so down on your luck and such a sad, sad, pathetic soul right now.
Yeah.
You should apologize.
Oh.
Sorry.
This isn't something to be happy about.
Really.
Sorry.
Hi.
That's all.
Hello.
Thank you.
I shouldn't have hit it right on the bullseye.
I'm sorry.
It's so sad to think your life is over.
Yeah.
I know.
What should I do?
If I invite him in, I'll really become a...
A tout?
Tout?
Sorry.
Oh.
I forgot that when I...
Get out of the game...
But...
I'm so hurt.
I'm so sorry.
A tout?
I can't let you go.
Profit!
Thank you for the vibe.
Thank you.
I can't leave someone so hurt out in the cold.
A solicitor.
Oh.
I'll be a tout.
Hold on.
Well, it's, I think, a bit more accurate now, maybe.
No, not really.
But that's okay.
What do you mean?
That's right.
You don't have to come to the store today.
It's a type of fish.
Just to have a look inside.
Yeah.
It's like a salesperson.
Ah.
Got it.
You don't have to come into the shop.
You can just have a sneak peek.
That's right.
I don't know what's going on.
The truth is, I work here.
I didn't know they opened this kind of bar here.
It's some place where I can drink with girls.
So, when I was in Japan, for the two months that I was there...
Actually, by the way...
I was there by my train station.
Every time I would get home, there would be...
There was a bunny girl bar.
And it was kind of cold out.
So, the girl...
So, I couldn't, like, see them in the bunny girl outfits.
But they had, like, giant coats on.
And then the bunny ears.
I think it made it sexier.
Because I couldn't see, like, anything underneath.
But, like, you know, I could see their legs.
And I could see the bunny ears.
And I just imagined, like, the suit underneath.
And I was like, wow.
This is so sexy.
Keep the jacket on, girl.
Keep it on.
So, I was like...
I got to see bunny girls almost every day.
It was so awesome.
The power of imagination.
It's some place I can drink with girls?
That's like any bar in Akiba, to be honest.
I've never been in a shop like this before.
It's clean.
And the girls are so cute.
I guess I'll give it a try.
Oh, you're going to get me in trouble, sir.
Wait, why?
I can't come in?
Oh my god, you tease.
That's all for today.
I'll give you just a glimpse.
If you come inside, then I'm really a tout.
So, if you're interested, I'll be waiting for you at the next shop.
I give you the right to come to the shop as a customer.
Whenever you're interested, I'll be waiting for you to come.
Haha, you're so sincere.
Life isn't over.
It's okay.
Your life isn't over.
You'll be okay.
I know you will.
Oh my gosh.
Because of bunny girls, bunny girls will save me.
This place actually looks so fancy.
Huh?
It's a little bit, but it's a good smile, isn't it?
That's why it's not over.
Right now?
Even if it was small?
Sorry.
I've been so sleepy today.
I know you smiled.
That means you're not done yet.
Arigato.
I'll be waiting for you at this shop.
I'll be waiting for the next chance to see you.
I'm looking forward to it.
She's so country.
Haha, y'all.
I'll be here at this shop waiting for you.
I'm looking forward to the next time we can see each other.
Alright.
I'll be waiting for you.
What was her deal?
She was so strange.
She doesn't even know me.
It's interesting.
I like the 3D mix with the CD.
It's cool.
But I guess I do feel a little better.
I'm such a simple guy.
Me too, Haito.
I wish I could name myself.
Now I don't know if I really want to get drunk and forget everything.
I'm just gonna go home.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Wait, isn't that the Prison Princess Girls?
On the wall?
Also, when I saw that in a brief moment, I thought it was Fumoko.
I thought it was Fumoko.
Gorillas?
Is it sad that I recognized Prison Princess before Gorillas?
He's got his little iPad.
He's got his computer with sticky notes.
We're jobless now.
We are neat.
My life isn't over, huh?
More Japanese, please.
I'm in trouble.
What color were her eyes mint?
Green?
Wait, were they actually?
Let's go.
No way.
Why would I take something a girl said to me seriously when I don't even know her name?
Also, when she works at a bar that relies on ensnaring men.
She didn't even seem to be joking around, but you know.
They were green?
Oh my gosh.
I was tossing between green and purple.
I mean, it's not like anyone has ever told me that my life is done.
I'm the only one who thinks that.
If I don't finish it myself, maybe it's still possible to start again.
Finish what?
Oh, hello?
I'm sorry for calling you without notice.
You know how you were saying work was busy and you needed help?
Do you still need help?
If you'd like, would you take me...
Oh, Q!
What was that?
Oh no, I'm skipping.
It's been a week since I started my new job.
What should I use my money on?
Wait, I still have the same amount.
I haven't gotten any more money.
How much is 1,500 yen to U.S.
dollars?
Curious question.
Well, back in the day, it probably would have been about 150 U.S.
dollars.
But with the yen being as bad as it is now, I'd say about 100 to 110 dollars.
Yeah, about 100 bucks.
Sheesh.
96?
No way.
I saw like when people were going to like from Japan.
I saw like they were flying to Hawaii.
They were bringing...
They were bringing their own things.
They were bringing their own food.
Because the conversion rate...
Like Hawaii is already very expensive.
But with the conversion rate, it would have been so much more.
So they were like bringing their own food to like eat in Hawaii.
That's so sad.
That's so bad.
Hawaii is notoriously expensive.
Yeah.
The conversion rate is so bad.
That being said, me being positive is all thanks to her.
Should I go to that chick's shop?
Yeah, let's go see that chick.
Oh.
This week's salary...
Wow.
Nice.
Payment is made every Saturday for your new job.
Spend it carefully.
Cha-ching.
Gambling.
Album.
Vacation.
Wait.
Wait, I'm sorry.
You can gift a vacation to a cast member?
Not me.
I don't go on vacation.
They go on vacation.
Shop.
Purchase gifts to give to the cast.
My schedule.
You can apply for dispatch.
It takes two days for dispatch.
Do we not have a job anymore?
You can gamble.
You can view the photo taken.
You can sleep and let the day pass.
You can also rest your overworked body.
Save and load.
Interesting.
MC is a simp.
I think it was this shop here.
I'm a bit nervous though.
Wow.
I'm nervous.
Cute.
Ah.
The voice at that door.
Cute.
There's a bunny girl.
Ah.
Cute.
I'm nervous.
Vacation is fun.
Thank you.
I'm not scared.
Where is this?
Where is it?
Where?
Here.
Let's go.
OK.
Aaaahhhh.
Honey.
Oh my god.
Oh my, God, this is...
Oh...
Oh my, God.
Oh my, God, this is...
Sweet.
A....
basin...
Aрь?
Dilizon.
What did you see?
ViviCore, thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you!
The customer who looked tired, you came!
Oh, now we know her name.
I like the ribbon on her head.
That's right.
The customer who looked tired.
I'm here.
Which starter will Mint choose?
Yellow, red, or blue?
Blue!
That makes me happy!
I wouldn't know what simping is like, so this is a new experience for me.
Of course it is okay.
It's my birthday today!
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course, Melty!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Melty!
Happy birthday PyongPyong!
Hearing Maid Mint say my name again after all this time.
Dang, I'm lucky that Detective Manga is...
Hey Conan!
Oh, I just realized my thing kinda goes on my face.
Oh, there we go.
That's right, I've never been here.
I'll give you a brief explanation on how it works.
Please.
I don't know anything, so this will help.
The name of the shop is Bunny Garden.
A fun place to drink.
That's all.
Hmm...
It seems like I should understand.
But I don't.
Oh, well...
You'll get used to it eventually.
So I hope you'll visit a lot of places.
Well, you'll gradually get used to it, so it's okay.
I'll be really happy if you come here lots of times.
I agree.
To do that, I have to work hard at my current job.
He's already simping.
Maybe he feels like...
He feels like he owes her, you know?
He's just like, you saved my life.
So I...
I have to... I owe you.
I owe you, you know?
I like her... I like her... smug face.
It's over for my guy.
Well, then I want to be able to give...
...
I want you to be able to do your best, so I hope I can give you lots of healing!
That makes sense.
I feel like I can work harder if I feel better.
It's decided.
I didn't hear your order.
This is the menu.
She's so cute.
I'm sorry for what I said about her being too plain before.
I'll have a drink.
What drink did you want?
Customers must purchase a drink.
A pricier drink could increase your likability.
Let's see...
A Cassius orange.
Cassius liquor and specialty orange juice.
With a low alcohol percentage, it is popular among women.
Oh my gosh, the fanciest beer!
I've ever seen in my life!
Blueberry liquor.
I think I just got paid today, so...
This luxury champagne is rare and loved by celebrities!
It's very high in alcohol content, so be careful.
Lab Paris.
Highest quality grapes and aged for several years.
It's popular for its fresh and mature taste.
Oh...
I thought it said Mori Calliope.
I'll have a gin and tonic, please.
Coming right...
What?
Who is gin?
Shouldn't it...
Wait, isn't it spelled with a G instead of a J?
The green bunny girl saved my life.
What are you talking about?
Is it...
Is it because it's, like, copyrighted?
Sake.
It's a bit dry, easy to drink.
A fine wine.
Vintage umeshu.
Bunny trap?
Infused with a sweet, gentle aroma, many people tend to drink too much of it.
Bunny punch!
Has a high alcohol content, but women seem to be fond of it.
Wait, I'm drinking this, right?
Or are they drinking it?
Maybe I'll try the bunny max.
Has a partic... strong parti...
Peculiarity is not for everyone.
Oh, fill you up with power when drunk.
Recovering from depression.
Parasocial.
What do you mean?
No!
I mean, yes, now you're recovering from depression.
Yippee!
So this is my order.
Okay.
Let's go for the trap, because I feel like we've been trapped...
Wait a second.
Choosing for me.
Choosing for her.
I just noticed on the side.
I got paid today.
Let's get ourselves a bunny trap.
And...
We can get her the bunny punch.
I want to drink something too.
You can treat the cast members to a drink.
Some drinks that are more preferred than others.
And some are easier to get drunk on.
If you don't treat them to drinks.
They will prioritize other customers.
Treat your cast member to a drink.
I won't buy.
They will just leave me alone?
You saved my life.
Bunny...
Punch!
It tastes great.
Wait.
I should probably prioritize the girl that I want to...
That I want to get with.
Right?
Before I...
Spend expensive drinks on her?
Uh oh.
I think I messed up.
You can talk to the cast.
Something might happen.
Wait.
What does that mean?
You can give a gift to each cast member.
Once a day.
Gifts can be purchased from home.
You can treat the cast members to food.
There may be a preference for different foods.
Yes.
I have no presents.
Let's just talk to her.
Let's get to know her.
I'm getting kind of nervous.
Why?
I'm using therapy and medication.
The player character is the one recovering from depression.
I caught it.
Keep taking your meds.
I need your meds.
Are you alright?
She doesn't seem feeling well.
My eyes...
My eyes are up there.
What do you mean?
Wow.
Look at her bunny ears.
This must be the first meeting.
I'm so excited, nervous, and...
I mean, it's going to be the first time I meet this next customer.
My heart feels like it's going to explode from how fast it's racing.
But.
No.
It's no good.
This is the place where you're healing your customers.
Well, what am I saying?
The purpose of this place is to keep people safe.
Oh!
Thank you!
I will look into it!
But yeah, we're relaxed.
We're relaxed.
If I'm in a state like this, I'm sure the customer is going to feel the same.
Come on now, you've got this!
She's like saying all of this to my face.
Don't ask what my job is.
Let's start off with the usual.
The first step in order to become friends!
You're the customer, so please, go right ahead with everything you've got.
The first step...
Oh, okay.
What about a hug?
Oh, I'm cringing!
Oh, the toast is good.
The toast is good.
There are some things that affect likability.
Choose your words carefully.
Where's my hug?
Oh, come on, girl.
Come on, little bunny girl.
Where's my hug?
Let's do the toast.
So, a toast or something?
Sounds good.
I'm so excited to drink.
But...
After knowing each other's names...
She liked it.
Don't you think we can get along?
That's the spirit.
You seem eager to start drinking.
But don't you think sharing each other's names comes first?
I read your name tag.
Um...
Uh...
Wait, no.
Hold on.
Move your hands.
There we go.
Oh, she doesn't have a name tag.
Anime convention flashbacks.
I'd love to know more about you.
Right, my name is Mint Phantom.
Oh gosh, I'm so jealous of everyone named Haito right now.
I'm so jealous of everyone named Haito.
Wait, Minto?
Haito?
It's kinda close.
Right?
Y...
I need to keep looking at me like that.
!
H Ac Am Sh It
CR The faces are so cute.
I like actually how soft the features are.
Like, they look...
Um, like the... They just look really good.
I wanted to remember your name and face, you see?
So I was doing my best to store that into my head.
Yeah, they look so cute!
They're so cute.
But there's no need to worry.
I've matched your face to your name now.
My name is Kana.
It doesn't matter what you call me, but I don't want to forget your name.
It's my turn now.
My name is Kana.
I don't mind if you give me a nickname.
But I know... But I sure hope you remember me.
I'll give you a nickname, alright?
From this day on, you're Bitch-chan.
Alright, I'll do my best to match your name to your face then.
Bitch-chan... Bitch-chan... Bitch-chan...
Bitch-chan... Bitch-chan...
Have you guys ever seen...
Have you guys ever seen Diabolic Lovers?
Girl loves that.
That was his nickname for the girl.
Are you being mean?
No!
I'm trying to riz her!
What are you talking about?
I watched the Otomei show and I know now!
I know!
Stop it!
You're making me all flustered!
I didn't know it felt this embarrassing to be stared at!
I guess I got a little smarter from this whole situation.
Oh my god.
I kinda grew one brain cell that day.
Don't change the genre on your own.
Sorry!
Tell me more about yourself, Haito-kun.
I messed up real bad at work recently.
And because of that, the boss fired me.
So I've been assisting a friend at his work ever since.
Hmm... that sounds rough.
If I were in the same position, I'd be so upset that I wouldn't even be able to eat.
I can only imagine it, but...
Is this what the kids call negging?
What's that mean?
What's negging?
If it's what the kids call, I don't know.
If I was in your shoes...
I probably wouldn't even be able to eat.
Though I'm sure words can't express just how awful you must feel.
Oh, gaslighting.
Negative... edging?
I got it!
Oh, egging!
I'm so sorry!
Oh my gosh.
Negging is pick-up lingo.
For treating women horribly and they claim it gets all the women.
Oh, that sounds like diabolic lovers for real.
I'm going to do my absolute best in order for you to get back on your feet.
Okay.
I need to get myself together.
It's hot in here.
Try to be... I am!
I am!
I'm trying to be nice!
I'm trying... I'm using lingo that I learned from a show that apparently was bad.
I'm... I'm... I'm... I'm doing... I bought her good... I bought her the good juice, okay?
That time you spend here will be with a constant smile, I can assure you that much.
I hope we get along, Haito-kun.
I'm going to steal your soul until you turn into this black silhouette of yourself and you can never leave.
Haito-kun, what are you going to do with the alcohol?
I'm still okay, so if you don't mind...
Does that mean we go three times?
The one, two, three?
Haito-kun, should I get you more drinks?
I can keep going, but I'll only continue if you want to.
Ex... Oh, there's a fee?
Oh my god, this place is so...
Expensive!
And so real!
Oh my gosh.
Let's switch, yeah, yeah.
I thought you were going home already.
Oh gosh, I'm a sucker.
What drink did you want?
Wait, can I switch out?
Uh-oh.
Oh no, I'm stuck with her!
Dang.
Oh, I'm getting sucked dry.
Here, we'll go with the...
I'm gonna go with the sake and she'll get the blueberry liquor.
Can I have some too?
Oh wait, this is how I...
This is how I...
Switch.
A customer called me, so I better get going.
I was just cheapskating this guy.
I can't believe he's not buying me another drink.
I can't believe it.
Bye bye!
Who's gonna come over?
What's your name?
Hello.
Miyuka.
Nice to meet you.
Introduce yourself?
Would you like to introduce yourself?
Oh, she's so cool.
She's cool, isn't she?
Oh yeah.
You may call me Haito Kanda.
Oh.
You don't have to be polite with me.
I see.
I mean, okay.
I'm Haito Kanda.
I help my friend for work.
You help your friends?
Yeah, I was working at a company up until recently, but I got messed up and fired.
I don't know if that's like the first thing you want to keep telling people, you know?
I don't know if like...
Hi, I'm Haito Kanda.
I got fired recently.
Fired.
Right.
Are you bad at holding a conversation?
Are you a person of few words?
Are you angry?
Are you mad that I lost my money?
I got fired with Riz.
I'm thinking this one.
Maybe this seems not very offensive.
Are you a person of few words?
Oh.
I guess I don't speak much.
She doesn't even use an honorific.
She just calls me Haito straight up.
She hates us, you guys.
She hates us.
Yeah?
I'm sorry.
What does that mean?
Because I'm like this, I can't have a good time with Haito.
I can fix her.
I'm sorry I'm like this.
Maybe you won't be able to have a good time.
It's okay.
Who knows what will happen.
We just met each other.
I think it would be nice if we could just take things slow.
No rush.
We already started to get to know each other.
Thank you.
She's so cute.
Haito.
You're so kind.
You're a kind one, Haito.
Do you want to drink alcohol?
What are you going to do?
Get something ready.
She's so cute.
Do you want some alcohol?
What should I do?
Is there anything I should prepare?
Oh.
Extend?
Extend.
Here.
I want to drink something that is as good as my efforts.
You want to drink something that is as good as my efforts?
I want to drink something delicious.
What is it?
What drink did you want?
Let's do the same thing that we did with Kana in the beginning.
I got the bunny trap, and she got the...
Wait, do I have enough money?
9,000.
Just to save...
Wait.
Wait, is there a table charge?
Wait, is there only 2x... Wait, do I...
So, would it be 9000 or 6000?
Don't worry about it.
Okay!
I'm gonna have the bunny trap.
Can I have a drink with you?
Oh, our little Chibi is so cute.
I'm gonna get you the bunny punch.
I did it!
I like this.
I'll
have it.
Oh, I'll have it!
Oh, cute!
Cute, cute, cute, cute, cute!
Oh, I think you just dumped it all over the ground.
She took one sip and was like...
Oh wait, no!
They put their drinks under the barley!
I like that!
There's like a little shelf there.
Oh, that's so cute!
Do you want to talk about something?
Is there anything you want to talk about?
You think tomorrow will be...
Oh yeah, the weather deck.
Let's go.
You think tomorrow will be sunny?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Shall we look up the weather forecast?
Are you curious about the weather?
Are you always curious about the weather?
Not really.
I'm just making small talk.
Sorry.
I made you worry.
I didn't mean anything by that.
This is a business venture and Buddy's stonks are through the roof!
Yeah!
If you do go bankrupt, just get a loan.
They will understand.
Watching you play this on my birthday is certainly interesting.
Xeno!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Xeno.
Happy birthday!
I love blue women.
Ah, so true.
Gosh, she looks like one of my...
She looks like an Oshii I had that graduated.
I mean, except in...
Maybe the... the... the... the...
The one repop...
But she...
I can't stop seeing my Oshii.
I'm always like this.
Is that okay?
This is who I am.
All the time.
Is that okay with you?
It's alright with me.
We're just starting to get to know each other.
That's weird.
You're a peculiar one.
You laughed just now, didn't you?
You have a cute smile.
Thank you.
Wolfhound, thanks for the 20 gift!
It's getting late.
I should go home soon.
Oh!
Um...
So it is 9,000.
Oh my god.
If you can please the cast members in the shop, they will see you out in a good mood when you leave.
We pleased them.
We did a good job.
Haito, who is sent off, is more motivated to work and earn a higher salary for one week.
Higher motivation for work can lead to a raise and an increase in base salary.
Thank you for today.
See you later.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
I'll be back.
Wow!
Turtles, thank you for the Akatoro!
I mean, Akatsuma!
This should make up for part of the memberships I missed these past years.
Also, my tickets to your karaoke bar.
I can't stop listening to them.
Stop!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
There was no ticket.
What are you talking about?
Yeah.
Thanks for everything.
See you soon.
So it's this place here, right?
What?
Oh man, I'm gonna get a bento after this.
It was such a nice place and the customer service was great.
Maybe I'll go there for the time being.
I love Bunny Garden!
Oh!
What can we get?
You can purchase gifts to give to the cast.
On rare occasions, the lineup may change.
Socks!
Gucci socks!
Perfume.
Makeup.
Plush.
That is a really expensive plush toy.
Holy cow!
Macarons?
I'm thinking the macarons are a good gift, right?
See?
It's Gucci but with a Q.
So wouldn't it not be Coochie?
I want macarons now.
I'm thinking about them.
When I was...
When I lived in Japan, at Family Mart, they released like a pack of two macarons.
One was strawberry flavored and the other one was pistachio.
And I'd get it like once a week.
It was so good.
I'm drooling.
Yummy.
Which one was better?
I think I like the pistachio.
The pistachio one was really...
Oh my god!
Turtles!
Tickets!
Sorry about the table!
Stop!
Thank you!
Okay.
Let's get some macarons.
Cha-ching!
What's my schedule?
You can check the schedule except...
Her birthday!
Oh.
Okay.
We can only stay up until September.
What is the dispatch?
Oh, we're not recruiting.
Okay.
You can get the vacation to a cast member who invited you.
We can go...
Oh wait.
Continue.
There we go.
We can gamble.
You can try gambling.
Of course, sometimes you win and sometimes you lose.
Keep your fingers crossed and consider taking on the challenge.
Um, yeah, I do wanna gamble a little bit.
Gambling.
Win!
That's a lot of money.
That's a lot of money!
No, no, no!
Save, save the game.
Save the game!
Oh my god, it's so cute.
Is this a hobby?
What does that mean?
Oh, I don't have any.
I thought I took that picture.
Yo...
Oh, sold out.
Okay, time to go to bunny garden.
I'm rich again.
Now is my time to rest up and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
I think I am Haito and I'm realizing very quickly that I have a problem.
The cast member who likes you the most will serve you immediately after you enter.
Increase your likability and you might end up with the cast?
Oh, you came!
I'm glad.
What drink did you want?
Hmm...
Just give me...
Honka badonka Jesus!
Miyuka...
Is that... wait...
Miyuka is the short-haired one, right?
I am still curious about the other girl, but I feel like she's kind of out of my league.
I feel like she's kind of like...
The type that would scare me.
You know, like...
The one that's like...
Like she's so... like she's too... she's too social, you know what I mean?
Give her a chance?
Maybe...
Women scare me.
Yeah, just gyaru, gyaru, gyaru.
So true.
Let's get... I'm gonna get just a...
I'm gonna get a fine wine, because I... I earned a lot of money gambling today.
Can I have some too?
No.
See ya.
Who's coming?
Who's coming over here?
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
It's Miyuka!
Sure, what's up?
Why'd you have to do the hand gesture with it?
You got fired.
Yeah, I'm the... I'm the guy that got fired.
Yes, thank you.
You're not gonna let that go, huh?
Sorry.
Name?
She doesn't remember my name.
Fish want her.
Women scare her.
What's your name again?
Hito Kanda.
Hito.
Minto.
Everybody, remember my name.
I'm Minto.
I'm Mint.
Minto.
Hito.
He came again.
They're back again.
I came to see you, Miyuka-chan!
Should I have not come?
I just ended up here.
I'm Mint.
No, you're Murphy.
I don't care if you've got that silly wig on.
You sure?
I'll let you know!
Nope.
I'm not a doctor.
I know you're scared of me!
I don't know what to say!
Just be quiet!
I don't like you!
I don't know what to say!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
In the first place...
I don't know what to say!
I was having a hard time...
So, I'll try to explain myself...
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I have one, actually.
No, I meant... No, me!
Play hard to get?
Should I have not come?
No, it's not that.
You must be low on money, though.
Don't worry, I gambled!
This is a collecting mission.
You have to charm all the girls.
We can't let the other customers have them.
Use code 880.08 Got it, Colonel!
You're that curry ninja.
I'm helping out my friend now, so it's OK.
You don't have to worry about that.
I'm not worried.
OK.
Is it my turn to be mint?
Never!
Unless I possess you.
Actually, I'm mint.
No, me!
Me!
You must spend your money wisely.
It's necessary to live.
Yeah, I'll make sure to do that.
All waifus are OSPs?
Thanks for coming here to spend that important money.
You're welcome.
Thanks for showing me...
I have a gift for her!
I feel strange to say you're welcome after that.
Aw, you smiled for me again.
It's so creepy when we say that.
You still haven't had enough to drink.
Do you want to order anything else?
I too am also mint.
Stop!
Oh my god, this face is the cutest.
What should I drink?
Should we try...
What's the other girl's name?
You mean Rin?
That's what you guys said?
Mhmm...
Umm...
Okay,
let's try.
I'm going to get something cheap.
Can I drink with you?
Oh...
Sorry...
Thank you for all the super chats, you guys!
Thank you!
Looks like a customer is calling, so I better get going.
Bye bye!
She's so cute!
Oh my gosh, Wei, she's so cute!
She's so...
Sorry,
I got that gamer posture.
She calls me cute!
Why are you curled up in a ball, sir?
What's wrong?
She's really cute.
He must be nervous.
That's no good.
Getting nervous over me is just a waste of energy.
Hello, my name is Haito Kanda.
It's a pleasure to meet your acquaintance.
Ukeru!
She's too gyaru.
So dazzling!
That's hilarious!
Ukeru!
You started introducing yourself.
Then I'll introduce myself.
Hello, my name is Pin.
I'll lend you a hand.
What is this?
Is this okay?
Suddenly speaking in Keigo.
I will too.
Hello, I'm Rin.
Pepper
in my throat.
I had a pepper in my throat.
Oh, my God.
I'm crying.
Girl started coughing and straight up passed away.
Oh, my God.
Hold on.
I'm going to go get some more water.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Give me one second.
I'm so sorry.
I told you, it's the gyaru.
It's the gyaru.
I can't deal with the gyaru.
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
I'm back with baby tomatoes.
Okay, Rin is actually trying to...
Actually trying to...
Like, exercise my soul.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
That's a-okay.
Hai-chan.
What do you do, Hai-chan?
Right now, I'm assisting an acquaintance with their job.
Oh, my gosh.
You can't keep saying that.
You're such a mess up, my guy.
Stop saying...
Don't say a plethora...
Okay.
Until recently, I was employed at a company.
However, due to a plethora of mistakes, I was terminated.
That does not make you look good.
Why are you...
Why are you saying that?
Why...
This guy has the worst, like...
Elevator pitch ever.
Wait, Hai-chan.
I'm not good at honorifics.
I don't know how to talk or listen.
That's why...
If you stop using honorifics...
I'll be really saved.
I'll be really grateful.
I get her, though.
I get her so much.
Hang on, Hai-chan.
I can't keep up with the...
Keep up...
Keep up with all that formal speech.
I'd be, like, super grateful if you could just, like, talk normally.
Boy failure.
So true.
Oh, really?
I'll drop the pretenses, then.
Thank you.
What?
Hai-chan is such a kind person.
It's not good for a company to appoint such a person.
It's better to fire her rather than fire her.
Thank you.
You're such a nice guy, Hai-chan.
It's, like, their loss for firing you.
You're, like, way better off without them.
She's so cute.
Oh, my gosh.
Look at her.
Look at her smug little face.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
I think I like Rin a lot.
No, they treated me pretty well.
But I'm getting by okay now.
Yeah.
Hai-chan, you're just so great.
I respect you for not blaming the company that fired you.
Wow.
You're really something, Hai-chan.
Like, you won't even badmouth them, even after getting fired.
I respect that.
Yarumin, my dreams come true.
What dreams are you having?
You're often told that Hai-chan is a kind, decent, and good person.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna give her my macarons.
You're, like, a stand-up guy.
You must get that a lot.
A lot, huh?
Let me hear some more.
Who is they?
They do.
You must get that a lot.
They do what?
Who?
I want some more.
Oh, yeah.
Let me hear some more.
Hai-chan, you're a kind, decent, and good person.
You're really kind, decent, and good person.
Oh, my God.
I paid for this service.
You know what?
You're such a kind, upstanding person, Hai-chan.
It's so true, you know?
You're so kind and so upstanding.
Like...
How is that?
Oh, yeah.
You know what?
I'm gonna tell you something.
I'm gonna take this seriously.
I'm always serious, but seriously serious.
Seriously.
Seriously serious.
Meeting new people is really important, right?
In life.
That's why I'm grateful for meeting you, Hai-chan.
So I'm really grateful to have met you, Hai-chan.
Oh my gosh, she's so sweet.
I'm hook, line, and sunk.
Gosh, I've been fished by Rin.
I think so.
I may be far from perfect, but I'll still do the very best I can.
Hope you're ready!
Oh my god, look how cute she is!
She's just a silly girl!
How embarrassing!
Wait, like, what am I saying?
I'm just, like, so silly.
Well, you get the idea, right?
Did you catch all that?
Because I won't say it again.
Ukeru!
Besides, the other girls are all good girls.
I'm sure you'll like this place.
Oh my god, and she's even vouching for the other girls.
She's like the best.
She's a girl's girl.
She's an everybody's girl.
She's so great!
Focus on the prize and keep glancing at the other two girls.
I'm trying to decide, you know?
You know?
But it is kind of like one of those, like, when you see the other girls, you're like, what am I missing out on, you know?
By the way, the other girls here are all really nice, too.
I think you'll like this shop a lot.
If you find that I'm not your type after talking to me a few times, feel free to sats...
sa...
s...
siddle...
so...
saddle...
s...
slide...
What does this mean?
siddle...
Up next to another girl instead.
Oh my god, she's so sweet.
I'm not the type of girl who's, like, bothered by that sort of thing.
Write me a letter.
I'm not the type who's bothered by that sort of thing.
Well, on the other hand, if you do find that I'm your type, it'd make me, like, pretty happy.
Oh, I didn't know you were that kind of person.
So, I'm getting the hang of it.
See you, Hai-chan.
I don't know how I feel about her, like, rubbing her hands though, like a...
like a bond villain.
Maybe she...
Maybe she's coming?
Maybe she's a little more evil than we know, you know?
She's like, yes!
Yes!
Yes, buy the bunny trap!
I'm not the type to get upset about those things.
But you know you want to stick with me.
Yes!
She's scheming.
Well, I'll leave it at that for now.
With that said, I look forward to serving you, Hai-chan.
Have you not had enough to drink, Hai-chan?
If you want some more, I can get you some.
Ah, yes.
You did it!
I was about to get so lonely!
She has the same embarrassed pervert smile as me.
What are you talking about?
What do I want?
The bunny trap, of course.
Wait, does it even matter what I...
So wait, I guess it does matter what I order.
Because the more I spend, the more they like me, right?
So...
So it's just an overall price.
Yeah, yeah.
It's delicious, isn't it?
This tastes so good.
Itadakimasu!
She's so cute.
It's delicious!
Let's give her the present.
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this?
I hope you like it.
Oh, Azumas?
Azumas?
I got something good.
I'm not good with honorifics.
I really can't.
What is that?
Can we rizz all three?
Can our wallet handle it?
I don't know.
Man, I'm really no good at this formal stuff.
I just can't do it.
What good is it anyway?
It's meant to show respect to the person you're speaking to.
Haha, I know what you mean.
But even if it's not formal language, you're still a parent, right?
Yeah, I know that much.
But you can still show respect without it, right?
Oh my god, she messed up her words.
So cute.
I guess it's a way to easily convey that to respect the person.
That's a simple thing.
I don't think you need it, but it's a pain in the ass.
That's too on the nose.
I don't think that'd be necessary.
It'd be annoying for one thing.
Some people place a lot of importance on that sort of thing.
Can we get drunk in this game?
That's true.
I don't know how many times I've been drunk.
Oh, that's true.
I can't tell you how many times I've been snapped at.
Well, but...
You can.
You can?
Where's the drunk meter?
I guess I don't want to leave people with rotten feelings either.
I've got no choice but to brush up on speaking more formally.
Oh wait, this is good practice for me too.
Hahaha.
The best way is to learn through experience.
I'll try it now.
Okay, let's start!
Are you doing well, Rin-chan?
Yes.
Do you enjoy this job?
Is she only just going to say hi to everything?
Yes.
Do you like formal speech?
No.
No?
Do you have any hobbies, Rin-chan?
Reading.
Let's stop, Rin-chan.
You're fine the way you are now.
Wow, is it already this late?
I'm going to go back.
Oh my gosh, I think I'm losing brain cells just talking to her.
Thank you, Rin-chan.
Bye-bye.
See you tomorrow.
Thanks for everything.
See you soon.
I'm motivated for...
Ah!
That's what I imagined.
That's like...
Oh!
I didn't see them tomorrow.
Oh, I got paid a lot though.
Gambling time.
Come on.
Kamisama!
No!
Okay, one more.
One more.
We'll see.
I know I save scum, but I want to...
I want to have...
I want to have the belief.
That...
Wait.
The red eye?
That wasn't there before, right?
This is good, right?
This is good?
Oh.
We can win it back.
Gambling buns.
This is it.
We'll win it all back and then some.
Yike!
I think...
I think we won it all back.
Actually.
I don't think we made even a single...
A little... Yenny back.
Oh, still down?
Okay, one more time, one more time.
5K short.
Oh, two!
Two eyes, two eyes.
Two eyes, two eyes, two eyes.
Really, really, Mint?
Really.
One more, one more, one more.
One more.
Uh-oh, it's two eyes again.
I don't trust it anymore.
Congratulations on your silver button.
Thanks, Joshua!
I like how whenever you're eating sometimes, you sometimes pout in and out.
Even during yesterday's stream.
It's so cute, like a little chipmunk.
Or dare I even say it, a bunny.
Stupid.
Stop watching me eat.
Okay, well that's the last one.
This is it!
This is it, this is it, this is it, this is it, this is it!
Come on!
I think we should reset the save.
I think we should... Oh no, no, no!
I pressed, I pressed, I pressed one more on accident!
I pressed instinctually instead of the go back.
Uh-oh, oh god.
It's okay, we're gonna reload anyway.
Unless...
Ooh!
Not enough though.
Okay.
Most gamblers quit just before they win big.
I know.
What else can we buy?
Hmm.
I think she would like a necklace, but I'm not rich enough yet to really... Oh, perfume!
She would like that.
Mm-hmm.
Motivation up!
Okay.
One dispatch consumes two days.
Be careful not to overwork and ruin your health.
Okay.
We can get so much more!
Any hairstyle.
Inaba, inaba, inaba.
Just gamble more.
It wastes a day though.
Yeah, you're right.
I don't know.
It's not that much for just...
Well, actually it's more than I...
It's more than I made in a whole week.
But with just one day, right?
No, two days.
It wastes a week.
But then do I also get the money from my friend on top of that?
Do I also get the...
Gambling looks more worth it.
Gambling is safer?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I made 500...
Wait, I made 57k?
Oh, just kidding.
Never mind.
Get out of here.
I can gamble.
The game says I can gamble.
What a gamble.
Just once.
Just once, you guys.
I'm preying on you, big boss!
Boss!
Woo!
Don't pray to God.
Pray to big boss.
You wanna continue gambling?
No, okay.
Now I'm gonna go spend lots of money on girls!
Now is my time to spend money.
I mean, rest up and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
Woo!
Cast members may be away on Saturdays.
Why not try having a conversation with other cast members?
Thanks, Rin-chan!
What are you drinking?
What?
Hmm...
I won big today!
We're getting...
Oh, wait.
If I get this...
I want that for her.
You're a simp.
Yeah, I am.
Thank you.
I'm simping for my bunny, Oshii.
So she has funds to simp for other bunny girls.
The circle of life!
Stop!
Yeah, get that for her.
Okay, I'll get the bunny trap again.
Of course, Rin-chan!
G-g-g-g-g-g...
G -g-g-g-g-g-g...
Ta-da!
Really?
Hurray!
I'll get the bottle!
This is like... so actually at maid cafes, you can do stuff like this too.
And like a lot of cafes, like themed cafes in Japan...
Like you can buy a champagne bottle and just like...
Share with the girls and stuff like that.
Sometimes you can...
I think sometimes you can even buy a bottle and just for the girl to keep.
Like you don't even get to drink any of it.
Wow!
That looks more than before, right?
Am I crazy?
That looks like the more... the more... the more... the more...
Lacey, a little bit.
I have a present for you.
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this?
I hope you'll like it.
Azumas?
She liked it.
I'm glad you came back.
Thank you!
Like, have you been good?
Yeah, you seem like you're in a good mood too, Nin-chan.
Brain MC only, but...
What good would I be if I couldn't put on a smile?
I'm fine.
You actually don't look like you're feeling so great yourself.
Really?
I'm feeling fine physically today and I don't have any problems.
I'm not?
You're definitely not feeling good.
Not at all.
This is a bad omen, you know?
Get it?
Today's fortune!
Oh my god, she's an empath!
Yeah...
Oh my god, no way.
Not only is she scamming me, like, in the bar, but she's also scamming me.
She's a scamming fortune teller too.
Oh my god, no!
Where's Kana?
It said she took the day off.
On Saturdays, it said that they can sometimes take the day off.
But hey sir, you're lucky.
In fact, I can judge based on your name.
Wanna try?
Like fortune telling with names?
Sure, I'll give it a try.
Okay, okay.
Um, I know your name.
You told me about it the other day, right?
Mm-hmm.
Do you remember it?
I know your name already.
You told me what it was last time, right?
Yeah, I introduced myself to you.
Yeah, I know, I know.
I know, but it's not that.
It's not that.
It's the kanji, right?
The life judgment.
I've had to do this before.
One time, one time I... I met someone that I had met before.
But I couldn't remember their name.
And I had to write down their name for something.
And I was just like, oh, hi.
Um, I'm taking everybody's names.
I just need to make sure it's spelled correctly.
Can you let me know how to spell it?
And they were like...
It was like the most simple name ever.
I don't even remember.
It was like... like Mike or something.
They were like, Mike?
And I was like, oh.
Yep.
You know, I could have been with like... I don't know.
A C?
A Q?
So I was like...
Thank you.
I need to know how it's spelled to do the fortune telling.
How do you spell your name in kanji?
Oh, she's at... see... you can get away with that in Japan, right?
Oh, actually...
Should we do Kanda or Haito?
Hmm... she likes to be formal.
I mean, not formal.
She likes to be informal, so...
Mike.
It's spelled in Hiragana?
Oh, she might like that too because she's dumb and she can't spell... she can't write the kanji.
It's spelled in Hiragana.
No way.
Then my strategy is totally... darn.
I read that this would be 100% foolproof.
First the character's for Cup and Person.
Then Dry and Field.
That's how you spell Haito Kanda.
Do you remember now?
Cup and person.
So...
Oh wait, see I was thinking Kan... like the Kami-sama Kan.
And then...
Da is field, yeah.
The rice field.
Cup person dry field.
Cup person!
You got me, huh?
I like totally forgot your name.
Really sorry.
Aw, she looks sorry.
She's cute.
She tried, you know?
She tried.
Cup head.
I found a way online to learn someone's name after you forget it.
I set to offer to tell their fortune with it.
Clever, huh?
How did you figure it out?
Was I acting suspicious?
You seem like the type of person who can't tell a lie, Rin-chan.
It was written all over your face and how you were acting.
I get it.
People often tell me you're a pervert.
People usually tell me they can read me like an open book.
To be honest, I'm going to live.
In the first place, it's hard to cover it up with a lie.
It's better to talk honestly, get scolded and apologize.
Sorry, I totally remember.
How do you spell your name again?
Mint.
Mentos.
First with an M, just like my arms.
Then with an I, I'm standing tall.
Then with an N, no other way.
Last is a T.
Take it away.
Mint.
You guys are still spelling it wrong.
Did you freestyle that?
I freestyle everything.
I'll live honestly.
It's like so tiring to cover things up with lies.
It's easier to just be honest and then apologize when you get scolded.
I'm really sorry, Hai-chan.
You told me your name, but I forgot it.
I was trying to fool you.
I'm really sorry.
I'm really sorry, Hai-chan.
You told me your name, but I forgot it.
And I tried to pull the wool over your eyes.
I'm really sorry.
It's alright.
It didn't bother me at all.
It just matter.
How am I supposed to be mad?
Made menthol stuff.
For real?
Like, yay.
Let's kick back and have some fun.
We'll go extra hard today to make up for my...
Make up for my screw up.
Tint.
No.
I said M like my arms.
Do you want to go out for a drink?
Time totally flies when I'm with you, Hai-chan.
What should we do?
Will you stay with me for a few more rounds?
Yes.
Alright!
Let's continue.
Actually...
Alright.
Let's go.
What do you want to drink?
I think I've already spent a good amount of money.
So I'm going to get a highball.
An elegant finish that cannot be found at other places.
Made mic stuff.
Of course.
Wait, I already got this, right?
Yeah.
We're going to get you...
Let's get you the...
The bunny punch again.
You like this, don't you?
Because it's delicious.
Delicious.
Here we go.
I've got to reach for it.
It's written like...
Bink.
No!
What's the food?
Oh, edamame!
Oh my god, pizza.
Wow!
Quality suit...
I feel like these should be switched, right?
Special parfait.
Hope you're enjoying your time with the spiciest yellow bunny girl, Rin Minto.
Thank you!
Yes.
Pizza.
Additive free pizzas.
What?
This place is fancy.
Assorted candies.
Salad.
Rich flavor.
Everything is...
A lot of potato flavor.
When she rubs her hands together, I can only see the guy in the yellow suit behind the tree meme.
What's that one?
My Kamiyoshi Michael Phantom.
That's not my name.
I want some french fries.
This is delicious, right?
Delicious!
Hai-chan.
Are you a ghost?
No, I'm not a ghost.
Something is wrong.
Are you okay?
No, I'm not.
Are you okay with ghosts?
What about you, Rin-chan?
Are you afraid of them?
Okay.
This...
Rin-chan, don't let me down.
Don't let me down, Rin-chan.
This is...
I know I am.
Thank you.
All natural pizza.
Fresh off the pizza tree.
Don't let me down!
Don't let me down, Rin!
Don't play with me!
If someone shows up in front of me, will I be a hit on the spot?
W-w-w-w-welp.
W-w-w-w-w-welp!
If one showed up in front of me, I'll smack it!
S-smack it.
I guess I would.
Look at her face, though.
Is she...
I'm not afraid of them.
Right?
People are just scared of them.
Like, all they can do is startle you, basically.
I guess it's time for my username to be...
To be relevant again.
Thanks, ghost hacker!
I can do way more than just startle you, Rin.
Have you ever seen a ghost before, Rin-chan?
I haven't.
I wish one would show itself to me at least once.
I'm right here!
I'm right in front of you!
Wait, so she can smack me?
Yeah, maybe they're afraid of you because they think you're going to smack them.
The poor things.
I just want to see one.
Maybe you'll meet one if you hang around abandoned buildings or haunted spots.
Or, you know, like an abandoned maid cafe!
I can't!
Abandoned buildings are way too scary!
No way!
Why is chat spamming Bustin?
Am I missing something?
Are they?
To be honest, I didn't notice.
I thought you weren't afraid of ghosts.
I'm not afraid of ghosts because they look weak.
But I'm afraid of monsters.
What?
Weak?
Excuse me?
Ghosts seem weak, so they aren't scary.
But if a monster jumped out, I'd be terrified.
Not weak...
Abandoned buildings are dark and damp, you know?
Monsters like places like that.
They could pop out for sure!
Sure.
I thought monsters and ghosts were basically the same thing.
Um, actually...
Yabakunai?
Um, actually, not at all.
They're totally different.
I could never fight a monster.
Those guys seem tough.
They're huge with fangs and claws.
Too risky.
She's kinda cute when she's scared.
Ah, so scary!
That'd be awful if I thought about those monsters tonight!
Do you need someone to... I could be the...
She's gonna think about me.
W, just like your arms.
E, like the ectoplasm you're made of.
A, all of the simping.
Okay, the response this dono deserves.
Weak!
Weak.
Weak, weak, weak.
If that happens, I'm blaming it on you, Hai-chan.
Next time I see you, I'll smack you.
Just kidding!
For free?
You have fangs.
I have one fang.
Time to extend!
Let's continue.
All right, all right, all right.
Um, I want something that's gonna... Oh!
Depending on the person, it seems easy to become intoxicated.
I want something that's gonna make me drunk!
Yeah... What does she like?
Um, I think I've spent a lot of money.
Does she like, uh...
Like a lemon sour?
No, everybody likes a lemon sour, right?
Ghosts are kinda weak though.
Just hit him with a...
Ow!
Stop it!
Rin's armpit.
She like the berry bunny punch a lot.
Get Rin drunk?
Okay!
Oishi!
Drunk, drunk.
Yeah, girl!
We're getting ready tonight!
We're partying!
Itadakimasu!
Flat is best.
Flat is justice.
I mean... Flat is justice.
I'm just... But, you know...
I'm not gonna be against anything.
I'm a... I'm a...
I'm a booba connoisseur.
This is bringing back trauma about having to explain my overly-specific knowledge and lingo use with...
Gyaru bunka ga suki to a cute girl.
Let's talk.
What do you usually do when you're home alone, Rin-chan?
I usually watch anime, read manga, and play games.
That's all I do.
So you're an otaku too?
She's an otaku!
She's a keeper, everybody!
What?
Oh my god, best girl!
She's so good!
She's a gamer.
She's a... she's a anime enjoyer.
I usually watch anime and read manga.
Sometimes I play video games.
Isn't that about all there is to do?
Really?
I'm a bit surprised.
I thought you'd be more into girly stuff.
Gyaru poi!
So true!
What do you mean girly stuff?
Gyaru stuff?
Doesn't everyone watch anime and read manga?
She's a keeper.
What do you mean girly stuff?
Gyaru stuff?
She's just doing what she wants to do.
She's so great.
She's so good.
Rin-chan!
I don't care if something's girls or whatever.
I just do what I want to do.
You're right.
It's not good to make assumptions like that.
Sorry, Rin-chan.
No, I'm sorry.
I was just reflecting on what you said.
Do you think Rin likes girls?
Asking for myself.
If she does, we're both in luck.
No, I'm sorry.
I shouldn't have said it like that.
I don't blame you for thinking I was mad at you.
She's so real.
This is the route, Mint.
I know!
I didn't mean to sound like I was accusing you of anything.
But to be honest, I like making assumptions about other people as well.
What do you think about me?
You're so serious, so I was wondering what you were doing.
She's got such good fashion sense.
I wish she was the blue character, though.
Like, you know, I wish she was wearing blue.
I'll think things like, this guy seems serious.
He does... he probably does this and that.
Wow, you're so lame.
I'm sorry.
Even though I don't want to do it myself, I'm doing it for others.
No, it's okay.
I'm pretty dumb, huh?
I don't like it when people do it to me, but like, I still do it to others.
No one's perfect.
You gotta work it.
I love her hair.
She's so cute.
It's kinda like mine.
Maybe I should wear a side pony.
I'm kind of inspired right now.
Her hair is like mine, just different colors.
But I'd better stop.
Like, treat others like you'd want to be treated.
That's what my grandma always said.
She was definitely right.
So, in order to stop, it's important to know your partner well.
So, let's get to know you first.
He's just like me.
The best way to stop is to learn more about other people.
So, I'll start with you, Hai-chan.
Me?
By the way, what kind of person do you think I am?
At this stage?
Hmm... I guess I'm someone who made a mistake at work and got fired from the company.
It's no good, isn't it?
Decisions and prejudices...
Oof.
Right now?
You're like the kind of person who screwed up and got fired?
No.
I can't let myself make assumptions.
I need to fix my view.
It's not an assumption.
It's just the truth.
So, no matter how much we get to know each other, it won't change.
Wow.
Is it already this late?
I'm going to go back really sad and embarrassed.
Time to go home.
Thank you for today.
Please come again.
Bye-bye.
Thanks for everything.
See you later.
I got to drink some delicious alcohol and have fun conversations.
Now I'm motivated for work.
Sunday... Hmm...
Oh, wait.
Oh, sorry.
This one.
Let's gamble it.
I'm warning gamble.
Oh, big boss.
Big boss.
Boss.
Thank you for your boss.
Thank you.
Boss.
Boss!
Good.
Yeah.
No, you guys.
I didn't save on purpose.
Because...
This is real life.
Okay?
Keep rolling.
Okay, one more.
Just one more.
I wonder what the eyes sparklies mean.
If they mean anything.
Oh, it's only 800 yen.
One more.
Give me the jackpot.
Please.
Oh, God.
I'm going to lose my house.
Please.
The jackpot.
Ah...
Better than nothing.
Nothing.
Okay, one more.
Oh, God.
I'm scared.
I can't look.
Touching.
What are these tiny baby amounts?
I mean, not that I'm complaining or anything, but...
One more.
Okay, end on a win.
This is the last one.
Last one, last one, last one.
By the power of my bunny ears, I manifest money into my wallet!
I think I missed...
Last, last one.
You guys, I don't think I can... I don't think I can recover.
I actually don't think I can financially recover!
You're right.
I am.
This is what it's like when a Rona gives you nine blues and one yellow.
It's over.
It's over for me.
Who wanted to go see the bunny girls anyway?
You know what, maybe... maybe that girl was wrong.
Maybe my life really is over.
Maybe... maybe... maybe I just should have...
What a crazy dream we saw just then, wasn't it?
Oh my god.
You guys, I just had the craziest dream!
I'm so glad I woke up from that.
I just kept gambling and losing and losing and losing.
This is why I quit sports betting.
What did I do?
Gosh.
Anyway.
I shaved, brushed my teeth, and got the wrinkles out of my clothes.
I'm good.
Let's go into the shop.
I'm all dressed up fancy for them!
Hello, Rin-chan.
Of course.
What should we have?
I lost a lot today, so...
And also, I won't save Scub every time, you guys.
Don't worry, don't worry.
That's why I took the first loss, you know?
I'm gonna have a...
A vintage umeshu.
I'm gonna get wasted today.
Because I lost a lot of money.
Yeah, do you want...
Here, you know what?
Let's have the same thing.
Delicious, delicious.
I like it here.
I don't have a present for her or anything.
Let's just talk.
What do you do on your days off, Bean-chan?
What do you want?
Do you want to invite me on a date?
You're a meat-eating type, aren't you?
No, no, no, no, no.
Are you asking me on a date?
You're like pretty aggressive, aren't you, Hai-chan?
That's not what I meant.
I really am interested.
Is that so?
You're so boring.
Am I not that attractive?
Oh, I think you're very charming.
Of course I do.
I wouldn't come and see you if I didn't.
You're so attractive.
I'm going to get you.
I mean, I'm going to get you.
I'm going to be a little embarrassed.
It's funny that you think that.
It's so funny that it's actually a little embarrassing.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, you're so cute.
Thanks.
So is it my day off?
On the contrary, what do you think you're doing?
Anyway, you wanted to know about my days off.
Let's spin this around.
What do you think I do?
Oh, okay.
I have to judge her.
I think...
Okay, she said that she watches anime and she plays games.
So maybe spend time...
Okay, either shopping for clothes or spend time at home, right?
Right?
I think she spends time at home.
Spend time at home.
Oh, you're right.
That's pretty much it lately.
I've got like a stack of manga and this season's anime to catch up on.
She's so real.
I love her.
She also goes to karaoke by herself.
I like, went to karaoke in front of the station by myself last weekend.
I sang nothing but the songs that I wanted to sing myself.
She's just like me.
I guess you try to pick the songs that everyone knows when you go with friends.
Literally me.
I am also very cute.
I believe you.
Yeah.
I like hearing people sing.
But like going with friends is fun too.
Oh wait, so going with friends is fun too.
But like last weekend, I wanted to sing and blow off steam.
Just like me forever.
What were you doing last weekend, Hai-chan?
Were you making out with girls maybe?
No, I was here.
Obviously not.
I don't even know anyone who would want to.
Don't say that.
Hai-chan!
You can't do that without a partner.
Then, I'll do it for you.
Well, actually...
Yeah, I guess you'd need two willing participants for that.
Well then, why don't I act as your partner?
Here.
I'll blow a kiss to you.
That's all for now.
So hang in there, okay?
Okay.
Hai-chan, don't you have enough to drink?
If you don't have enough to drink, I can still get you ready.
Is this what it feels like?
To go to the afterlife one more time?
It's been so long since I knew what it felt like to die.
Goodbye, sweet world.
Umeshu, sounds great.
Umeshu.
Umeshu, right?
I hope I had enough to drink.
Look.
Look at her face.
She's so cute.
My Goodness.
If you want some more, I can get you some.
Yes.
Okay.
That's good.
Umeshu.
For me?
Umeshu for you?
Do you believe in life after afterlife?
Do you believe in life after life?
Should we get something to eat?
I love having... where is the mixed nuts?
Izakaya... or not Izakaya.
Bars always have the nuts that you can have.
Right?
Give more fries?
Pizza?
That's expensive pizza.
She likes pizza?
She does?
I mean, who doesn't like pizza?
Okay.
Well, we're not spending so much money today.
We just lost a lot of money.
So why not?
This is my favorite!
So yummy!
I hate pizza actually.
What?
Why?
Why do you hate pizza?
Are you having fun, Hai-chan?
Is there something you want to do?
I'll listen if there's anything you want to talk about.
Don't hold back.
Mint's streams have taught me that compulsive gambling and good alcohol is the real way to a woman's heart.
Thanks, Mint.
I'll take this knowledge to heart.
Oh, um, uh, yup.
I'm here to help you learn.
You're being pretty assertive today, Rin-chan.
What's going on?
She's drunk.
I thought I should try harder to starve my costar- well, serve.
Sorry.
Sorry if I read it wrong.
I thought I should try harder to serve my costar.
That's what they call good service, you know?
She's so awesome.
She's so awesome!
She cares about me, you guys!
I'm not parasocial!
She cares about me!
I mean, think about it.
You're spending your own hard-earned money to talk to me.
I'm not parasocial!
She cares about me, you guys!
She's so good!
She cares about me!
It's money!
Money!
Money that's valued equally all over the world!
I know I'm so- stop it!
And you're using that money to come see me, right?
Are you actually trying to tell us something, Mint?
Is your maid cafe actually a place to starve customers to turn you into a wuss?
No!
Why would you think that?
It's pretty crazy, right?
I can't just half-ass things now that I've realized how far people are willing to go for me.
I know I've bought her macarons, I've bought her perfume...
So that's why you're pushing harder today.
But to be honest, I prefer your usual style of service, Rin-chan.
What is going on?
Money!
Starve me, boss!
No!
Are you kidding?
My usual style is just me, like, goofing off!
I've never even been consciously providing service until now!
This pose is so goofy.
Instead of yourself, let me entertain you.
I can't just accept a paycheck for doing that, can I?
I need to make sure that I'm entertaining you, too.
Not just myself.
Hey, if you're having fun, then I'm having fun, too.
In fact, it wouldn't be as fun for me if you just started fussing over me.
Hmm...
Yeah, you're right.
I don't like being taken care of.
True.
It's not easy to relax when someone's fussing over you, huh?
Well, then I guess I'll just do what I usually do.
I'm going to buy her a big present next week.
Well, should I just act normal, then?
That'd be easier and more fun for me, too.
Sure.
I like you bust when you act like you usually do, Rin-chan.
You're plenty charming just the way you are, okay?
We got... we got some... we got some good points.
Yeah!
We're pretty coo- Don't say it with a straight face!
She's so cute!
That's embarrassing!
Don't say that with such a straight face!
I hope I'll be able to look you in the eye!
Oh, she's so cute!
It starves us!
I want to become an internal customer!
Well, I'm not...
I don't have to force myself to eat anything.
All right!
Let's keep going!
Yeah!
How does it taste?
Let's have...
What's her favorite, I wonder?
Can I have some too?
I'm going to get drunk-drunk.
This is delicious, isn't it?
Flesh and gyaru are very effective.
Thank you!
I'm being fed so well tonight.
Itadakimasu!
Have you realized you can control the camera when she reaches for your drink?
There's a zoom?
I didn't know when he told me this before.
It's a zoom?
Wait, is this real?
Really?
Do you have a phone, Hai-chan?
Are there any apps you spend a lot of time on?
You got games on your phone?
But I don't gamble or anything.
It's real?
We've been telling you?
I haven't seen!
What do you mean, we've been telling you?
I'm playing the game!
You mean like, are there any games or anything I'd recommend?
That's right.
But I don't care about games anymore.
I'm still being chased by my day-to-day life.
If I increase the number of games, I won't be able to enjoy them.
Yeah, but I don't need any more games.
I still have my daily routine.
I won't have fun if I do more.
Something other than games, huh?
Wait, I have it.
A map app?
Doesn't every phone have that?
A photo editing app.
She might like that, right?
Hmm...
The day alias.
I don't know.
She might like this, though.
Photo editing app.
Ah, right.
There are many people who use it by taking selfies.
I tried it once, but it was a pain in the ass.
She's not into the typical things a gyaru would be into.
You know, when you think of a gyaru.
It's just like shopping and makeup and everything like that.
I mean, I'm sure she's into it, but like...
You know, they are always heavily editing their stuff.
Yeah, no Riz.
A lot of people use this when they take selfies.
I tried using one once, but it was a pain to use.
I give up.
It's okay, I'll buy her another pizza.
Hai-chan, did you know?
People back in the day didn't have phones at all.
Isn't that amazing?
I don't have the confidence to live without a smartphone.
Isn't that crazy?
I don't think I could survive if I didn't have a smartphone.
I have it on my phone.
Yeah, me too.
Once you get used to having one, you just can't give it up.
She's so cute.
Exactly.
Maybe once you get used to me, you won't be able to give me up either?
If I get too into you, I might just want to keep you all to myself.
Hai-chan!
It's okay if you become one.
Just be yourself.
If you don't have me, you can't live without me.
That's great!
Are we?
We're like seriously flirting, aren't we?
Why don't you then?
In fact, you should.
Make it so you can't live without me.
Yeah, that'd be great.
So, from now on, keep getting more and more into me.
So from now on, keep getting more and more into me.
Okay?
I'll do
my best too.
Here.
I love you, love you, Hai-chan.
Come see me more.
Wow, is it already this...
No, Hai-chan!
No, you are in!
Don't go!
You idiot!
Come see me again.
I'll be waiting.
Thanks for today.
Bye-bye.
I can't believe it.
I'm motivated for work.
There are so many things to do.
What?
Woo-hoo!
Woo-hoo-hoo!
Uwa-ha-ha-ha.
Uwa-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Oh!
Oh, 700 yen.
This is better than losing!
Woo-hoo!
I mean, it's technically a win.
Hold on.
What stuff do we have in here?
Nothing has changed yet.
I think it's time to buy her the bouquet of roses.
The bouquet of...
Or, yeah.
The bouquet...
Well, maybe she...
She probably likes snacks.
Pajamas?
She probably would like pajamas a lot, right?
All right.
Seven dollars is seven dollars.
Exactly.
Because she likes to stay at home, right?
Okay.
If I win this next one, I'll buy her the pajamas.
Pajamas.
Why
does this keep happening to me?
Why does this keep happening to me, you guys?
Wait.
What the...
Oh, that is such a big amount of money.
Load.
Crazy dream.
Anyway... I'm buying her pajamas.
We gotta get in.
I shaved, brushed my teeth, and got the wrinkles out of my clothes.
Let's go into the shop.
She's here.
Thank goodness.
Yeah!
Our usual...
I'll get the umeshu.
I don't think...
Me, even getting drunk, maybe she's more like...
Like, you know, love you with me if we're drunk, you know?
Maybe we take more risks too because we get drunk, right?
But I think we're gonna give her the bunny punch.
This is delicious.
It's like... I pay so much more and I still get the same show.
Itadakimasu.
Pajamas made out of 100% cotton.
I have this for you.
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this?
Are you sure?
Thank you.
Oh, the E!
I forgot!
I'll get it next time.
Sorry, guys.
Are you into me, Hai-chan?
Hai-chan, do you like me?
Are you talking about me, Hai-chan?
Am I your favorite?
Sorry, I'll get the... I gotta get the big bottle and zoom in, you know?
What makes you think that?
It's not like I bought you so many presents or anything.
Well, you came to see me.
I know you like me.
Well, I'd be embarrassed if I misunderstood you.
I mean, you've been coming to see me pretty often.
I'm sorry if I got the wrong idea.
It's a bit embarrassing.
You don't have the wrong idea.
I enjoy talking to you, Rin-chan.
Be honest, yeah.
Really?
Then, do you remember what you talked to me about?
In that case, can you remember what we've talked about?
Oh!
You know,
we chatted about what I did on my days off, right?
You can't remember all the little details, can you?
Oh!
Combine words while remembering previous conversations.
Women don't like men who don't remember.
Um, you karaoke... sorry, karaoke?
Karaoke?
By herself?
With her cat?
That'd be awesome.
Karaoke?
In front of the station!
Jeopardy!
Good.
You really remember me.
I'm so happy.
What should I do?
Karaoke!
You guys, we did good.
We did good.
You really do remember.
Wow, that's crazy.
I'm like, so genuinely happy.
What should I do?
Yabai.
Atashi, chotto uzaku nakatta.
Jibun no koto okini deshou, toka.
Kaiwa oboeteru, toka.
Crap.
Was I acting kinda clingy just now?
Like, asking if I'm your fave?
And about past conversations?
Sonna no.
Nanka arejan ne.
Jishiki kawanae.
We're going in.
Let's go to karaoke with Rin-chan.
Yeah, let's go to karaoke with Rin-chan.
I really didn't mean it like that at all.
But I can't help it if you think I'm cringe and too self-conscious.
Nyaa, cringe.
I don't think of you that way at all.
Are you sure you should be saying that?
I get carried away sometimes, you know.
If I wasn't okay with that, I wouldn't come to visit you, Rin-chan.
Then, I'll make you my favorite too, Hai-chan.
So, from now on, let's meet properly.
She doesn't say that to everybody, you guys.
She's only saying that to me.
She only says that to me.
I'm her favorite now.
In that case, I'll make you my fave too.
So you better keep coming to see me, okay?
Where's...
What should I
do?
Of course.
Would you like to go out with me for a drink?
Oh dang, time like totally flies when I'm with you, Hai-chan.
What should we do?
Will you stay with me for a few more rounds?
I'm so whipped.
Alright, let's continue.
Let's continue.
What do you want to drink?
I'm gonna get... Okay, I'm gonna get something cheap for me.
We're gonna get the oolong highball.
Because we're gonna get the bottle for her.
Easy to get drunk.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cheap for me.
I know the zoom.
That's why I'm getting the bottle.
Of course.
Ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch.
Seriously?
Yes!
I'll go get the bottle.
Okay, here we go.
Zoom.
How do I go down?
Oh wait.
Control.
Here you go.
Automatically...
Just a glimpse.
I'm teasing you guys.
Oh, I wanna go on vacation.
Wait.
Is she gonna invite me?
That sounds nice.
Where would you wanna go?
A hot spring or maybe somewhere overseas?
I wonder if it's a holy place.
You guys, she's so perfect.
I wanna go to like a nerd pilgrimage.
I could visit places that inspired settings in anime and manga.
She's so good.
Yeah, I've heard of that sort of thing.
Some small towns have been revitalized because of it, right?
Perfect for Mint.
I shouldn't... I misjudged her so much.
She's so perfect.
She's so good.
In some places, the producers and local governments cooperate for collaboration events and stuff.
I wanna go.
Hai-chan, you wanna go with me?
I really wanna go.
Will you come with me, Hai-chan?
I'm interested, but it won't be as fun if I don't know the anime, will it?
That's true.
That's why I'm looking forward to anime collaborations.
Hai-chan, you just have to enjoy me.
You gotta take her to Hinamizawa.
Oh my gosh.
Bin-chan with Hinamizawa syndrome?
Oh la la.
In that case, I'll enjoy the anime collabs and you can enjoy...
What's that mean?
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean?
Enjoy you.
I can enjoy the anime collabs and you can enjoy the anime collabs.
Ah...
I see.
That's right.
Like, you can enjoy looking at my smiling face while I eat yummy food.
And you can feel my excitement while I buy all the anime merch.
So that's what you meant.
Going on a trip with you sounds like a lot of fun, Ninjan.
Are you expecting something bad?
You can't imagine that when you're traveling alone.
Were you thinking that I meant something naughty?
I guess you would imagine that if we were traveling alone.
No, I didn't.
I was picturing a normal, wholesome trip.
Really?
In that case, I feel kind of defeated.
Calls for more celebration.
Well, we need to get to know each other better before we go on a trip.
Let's put the idea on hold for now.
Take her to Uji and go sit on the Kumiko bench?
I'm an otaku!
But you know, I really wish I had someone to enjoy otaku stuff with.
It's fun by myself, but it'd be even better to share it with someone.
I wonder if she's not around...
Someone who understands my interests, and enjoys sharing them with me...
I'm here!
Isn't there anyone out there?
Anyone who understands my hobbies and will enjoy it with me?
Oh my god.
She's playing with my heart, you guys.
Need Ruan het wife.
Wife.
So true.
So true, she's so perfect.
Let's battle again.
Let's just go for the Ome show again.
Rin was born for mint.
She's just like me.
Sorry, I clicked out of the game on accident.
I
clicked out of the game on accident.
It paused.
I like the sound effect that it makes.
I'm gonna get demonetized.
Conversation.
It really was on accident.
We can't do it anymore.
I just can't.
Please, Hai-chan.
What can't you handle?
I get
it.
I can't stand it anymore.
There's a special edition release of a new anime out.
I want it.
It's got audio commentary from the director.
The director has a bonus.
I see.
Well, if you want it that badly, why don't you buy it?
Because I already have the regular edition.
I don't want to buy it again just for the bonus feature.
Oh, Rin-chan.
Rin-chan, are you a novice otaku or what?
Everybody knows that you buy at least three copies of the things that you love.
Especially, especially for the bonus.
Rin-chan, this is real.
Yeah, I think we can buy it for her though, right?
From the little rabbit shop.
Free demonetization, don't know.
Thank you.
But I'm not the type of girl who can just grin and bear it.
If there's something I want, I like can't stop thinking about it.
Are you the type of girl who can just grin and bear it?
Are you like that too, Hai-chan?
Or can you hold back?
I beg my parents to pay for it?
No, I can't hold back.
I can't hold back.
I knew it.
Wait.
I think people who can endure it are amazing.
But if you can't endure it, you'll be destroyed.
Uh-oh.
She didn't like it.
We have no riz.
I just wanted to be relatable to her.
Oh no.
No.
Oopsie.
Is this really the best answer to a hostess?
It's the best answer, I feel like.
Because if, say, she is my fixation, then I'm always going to be spending on her.
Right?
I think.
That's not how that works.
Anyway.
I knew it.
I think people who can...
who can are really amazing.
But if you don't hold back sometimes, you'll be broke in no time.
I've decided.
I'll hold back.
I have the normal version.
I won't waste it.
She's seeing how weak-willed I am.
You're right.
I've decided.
I'll hold back for now.
I already have the normal edition.
I won't waste my money.
Oh, I guess you can hold back after all, huh?
At the very least, I'll hold back until the sale starts.
I'll hold back until the sale starts.
I don't know if it's going to be a sale.
I'll at least wait until it goes on sale.
Once it does, I might crack.
But...
I'm really not good at holding back.
Maybe it's because I'm not greedy.
She wants a financially responsible man.
You're right.
But I'm really bad.
I really am bad at holding myself back like that.
Not just with physical things either.
What else?
Maybe...
If I can find someone I like...
Even if that person is super far away...
If I want to see them, I'll go right away.
Even if it's late at night.
Oh my god.
I can't wait for the arc when Rin shows up at my house at 3 a.m.
Like if I had someone I liked...
Even if they were super far away...
If I wanted to see them, I'd go right away.
Even late at night.
That's amazing.
Have you ever done anything like that before?
No.
But I'm confident it will happen.
Not yet.
But I'm sure it's the sort of thing I'd do.
I guess you're the type who really devotes themselves to people, huh?
Maybe it's a little different from that.
Hmm...
It's just that I can't go unless I want to see them.
Oh, well, not exactly.
I wouldn't go unless I really wanted to see them.
I see.
If you think about it, I might be a little troublesome.
She's so cute.
Hai-chan, if you fall in love with me, it'll be hard.
It might be hard.
Thinking about it that way, I guess I'm kind of a pain in the butt.
If you bother me, it'd probably be tough for you too, you know?
Oh, it's getting late.
Haito just leaves.
I'm like the best part.
Fighting down this guy.
I can't stand him.
I'm motivated.
Sunday.
Didn't you guys say that the gambling seems safer?
It's safe!
Oh my gosh, you guys, we did it!
We can't vacation yet.
Look how cute she is though.
Yes, yes, yes.
They're all cute.
But Nin-chan.
Nin-chan now.
They don't have it yet.
Let's get her some socks.
Oh yeah, let's save too.
Okay.
Here I go!
Now is my time to rest and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
Healing my mind.
Hello.
When do we get to like...
I've seen some stuff where you can take pictures.
I mean, obviously there's the album.
When do I get to take pictures with you?
I just took off my clothes.
I want to drink some with you.
Ah, thanks for the time gift.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Nin-chan now!
Okay, bunny patch.
This is delicious.
Checkies are first if I remember correctly.
Okay, should be soon?
Oh!
I forgot!
I forgot about those!
Zoom!
My bad.
Present!
I'll give it to you.
Picture time is when Rin decides it's picture time.
So true, she can do whatever she wants.
You know blood type personality theory?
That stuff's so ridiculous.
Do you believe in it?
I never thought that deeply about it before.
She a vampire?
She want my blood?
Like, you're type A, so you're very methodical.
It's so dumb.
There's millions of people with type A.
They aren't all the same.
I wonder, is it some kind of trend?
Makes sense though.
Going along with that trend, what type do you think I am?
Go on, guess!
Wait, I don't know blood types at all.
O is rare, right?
So...
O?
Don't call her A.
Yeah, I don't think calling her A would be good, right?
I do wonder though.
I do wonder if like, how badly you can mess up with these girls.
Once I like, play the game...
I want to like, do a fail run where I like, am so... so bad with them.
Okay, let's try type O.
Uhhh...
Nooo!
She doesn't want to be called type O?
Isn't that like the... isn't that like the rare one that people really want to be?
Type B?
What were type O's supposed to be again?
Laid back or something?
Well, I guess it's true that I don't sweat the small stuff.
B-gata!
I'm actually type B!
Oh, really?
That's A, B.
O can donate to anyone.
Oh!
O is the most common.
What is?
I don't know.
Hmm...
I think we lost.
We lost.
We lost...
Yeah, it wasn't even an opt...
Maybe she wanted to be called type A because she said she's methodical.
So maybe she wanted us to also say that she's methodical.
Do you guys know your blood type?
Actually...
I, well, I don't have blood.
But...
I don't even know what I would be.
I don't think I ever was told before.
Minus O.
O.
O plus.
I'm O plus.
I think I'm A.
What ectoplasm type are you?
Probably E.
It's like I've got the personality traits of all the blood types.
So blood type personality theory isn't reliable at all.
I think more than a few people would agree if you put it to them like that.
True.
They say that type A's...
Sorry, I get sleepy.
And type B's aren't compatible, right?
But my little brother and sister are type A and we get along great.
What's your blood type, Hai-chan?
I'm type O.
There's no way this many of you are type O.
E.
Yeah, I'm type E.
How compatible were type B and type O supposed to be again?
You don't believe in it, but you're still curious?
I wonder what my blood type is like.
I'm just a little curious.
I like this face a lot.
I was just wondering about how compatible we are.
It was just on my mind a bit.
That's all.
I don't believe in it, but if we're compatible, that would make me happy.
I don't believe in it much, but if the two of us were compatible, it'd make me happy.
This is bad.
When I'm with Hai-chan, time flies.
Why is this game...
making me feel things.
Extend.
She's making...
She's just so cute.
What did I get for her before?
I don't remember.
You know what?
Let's try...
Let's try a wine for the both of us.
Wine, wine, wine.
I should probably try all the drinks, right?
She likes it too, though.
Good, good.
In Japan, A is most common.
Didn't even say a single bit.
Wow, fancy wine.
I want to be good at games.
I don't want to lose anymore.
I want to get better at gaming.
I'm so sick of losing.
It's been stressing me out.
According to the NHS, people are...
O plus 35.
O minus 13.
A plus 30.
A minus 8.
B plus 8.
B minus 2.
AB plus 2%.
AB minus 1.
Wow.
I always thought that O was the most rare.
But I guess it's because...
Maybe I was just thinking of it being compatible with...
Like, if you're an O type, you can give blood to anybody, right?
I know what you mean.
Competitive games are fun, but losing too much can be a bummer.
Hey, Hai-chan.
I don't want to lose anymore.
What should I do to get better at games?
Hai-chan, I don't want to lose anymore.
How can I get better at video games?
Try it.
Oh, gosh.
Sheep tricks?
I think if I tell her to get good, she'll be upset.
Right?
I don't know.
Get good?
Okay.
We'll tell her to get good.
You just got to practice.
Yeah, Bustle.
Why do I listen to you guys?
You don't understand the way to a girl's heart at all.
Oh, my gosh.
I knew it.
It's like that with everything, not just games.
The only way to get stronger is work hard.
Oh, my gosh.
That's like so many responses in a row that we haven't gotten any hearts on, you guys.
What games do you play, Rin-chan?
I mean, have you ever heard of a simple game series?
It's like kind of popular.
But, you know, you might have heard of it because you're a gamer and all.
Do you think she plays Valorant?
Because losing can get stressful, I've had some problems.
Problems?
Sometimes when I lose, I scream.
Like...
Or...
Well, she should be an actual streamer.
Not a VTuber.
Oh, but hang on.
Even if I win, I might still yell out loud.
Oh yeah!
Or, take that, suckers!
VTubers are cute?
VTubers are cute too?
I mean, but like...
But like...
Isn't it nicer that us ugly people can become VTubers too?
And then when all the attractive people...
There's like some VTubers that also show their faces and stuff.
Must be nice, huh?
Must be nice to be a cute anime girl.
And also be able to turn into a cute human.
Must be nice.
But honestly, I don't mind.
Because as long as I get to look at cute things, I don't care how I look.
I don't care how I look as long as I get to look at cute things.
Maybe it'd be better if you soundproofed your room.
What do you want to drink?
Sake, yes!
What have we not tried?
I wonder if she is kind of weirdo.
Does she like the bunny macs?
Here, I'll just get my...
I'll get a beer.
Or maybe she'll...
Here, let's try a beer.
Actually, no.
I want to try the bunny macs.
Oh, she likes it.
But not like liked liked it.
Itadakimasu!
Kami-chan, what do you like about me?
My face?
Or my body?
I'm asking based on what I like.
You've come to see me so many times.
You don't dislike me, do you?
I keep making a bit of an assumption.
You like me, huh?
But you keep coming to see me.
So at least you don't hate me, right?
Hey Mint, are you winning so far?
I don't know, actually.
I can't tell.
I think she likes me though, right?
Of course I don't hate you.
But if you ask me which part of you I like...
Which part is a coco?
Which part is coco?
Which part do you mean coco?
Get a good look.
Here?
Or maybe here?
Maybe like this part?
I don't know.
What?
Are you embarrassed?
But what's embarrassing is this part.
She's so cute.
What's wrong?
Are you embarrassed?
Doesn't that seem backwards?
I'm the one who's embarrassed.
I like coco.
So please answer me quickly.
Which part of me do you like?
Hurry up and answer.
What part of me do you like?
Oh, your personality.
You keep your guard down, so it's easy to talk to you, Rin-chan.
Wait, Hai-chan.
Huh?
When I say sexy, you say coco or here.
But you like personality.
Bob.
I'm asking you.
Which part of me is sexy?
This part?
Or here?
But you're saying you like my personality?
She seems kind of upset.
This is unfair.
My
position is reversed.
I'm passing away.
She's so cute.
This is not fair.
I'm really starting to feel embarrassed.
How did you turn the situation around like that?
Well, it's okay because I'm happy.
W Riz?
No.
Still made me happy.
So you hang out with me because you like my personality.
When did it get so late?
Time to go.
Oh, Haito.
You dummy, dum-dum, dummy, dum-dum.
See you soon.
Motivated.
Motivation up.
I hope I get a bonus.
Give me more money so I can spend it on her.
Ooh, Haito.
This guy.
This guy has like...
Zero Riz for real.
He's so...
He's so funny.
It's like right as it's starting to get steamy, he's like...
Gotta dip.
Oh, my God.
The money.
I mean, we got the money.
We won.
Oh, shit.
Why did I say yes again?
I'm such an idiot.
I meant to exit out.
I did it on accident.
Rich.
I'm such an idiot.
I'm such a pervert.
But...
I got it.
I'm such a pervert.
I have to say it over again.
One more.
I can't wait.
I'm almost out of breath.
Hmmmm...
Too hot.
No,
this is a bit of an end.
Lame.
I need to...
Yes.
Hmmmm.
Mmmmm.
Mmm...
Excuse me.
Sorry.
Rin starts to lean into Hito and he hightails it.
He's just like, me for real, for real, for real.
One more?
The luxury bag?
Oh my god, I'll have no money.
I'll have no money.
Pajamas?
I already got her that.
Hmm...
She likes toys, so like plushies, right?
Let's get her the plushie, it's cute.
Shun-sui!
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you!
What should I drink today?
Beer?
Wine?
Champagne?
Let's just get in there first.
Go!
I'm going home.
Chat froze?
Oh, let me see if I can fix it.
There you guys are.
It's her day off, you guys.
It's her day off.
Give me the cashes.
Actually, I'll get the oolong highball.
You can get the cashes.
Actually, no.
Wait, I wanted to go home!
I wanted to go home.
I should've...
I should've just bought the drink for her and then didn't extend my time.
I'm wasting my money, you guys.
Oh well.
What do you like to do on your days off?
Play with my sister.
Go to the park.
She's cute though.
That sounds nice.
Is there a big age gap between you and your sister?
Oh, she likes to go to the park with her sister, is what she said.
She's still a second grader in elementary school.
Wow, that's a big difference.
What kind of games do you play with your sister?
Hide and seek.
Oh, you two must be close.
Because I'm the only one?
What do you mean by that?
My parents never died in accidents.
Moeka is alone with me.
I think Miu-kun's trauma is just a little bit.
I guess I got kind of asked, right?
I'm sorry, but my parents died in an accident.
I'm the only one my little sister Moika has.
I didn't know.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Yeah, it's okay.
Is it hard living together?
Just the two of you?
Maybe they're not lonely.
I don't want to say that.
Is it hard living?
Maybe it's hard.
More than me, Moika is...
I'm sorry, Moika.
Yeah, more so for Moika than I feel so sorry for her.
I can help you.
What do you mean by that?
It's okay.
Huh?
You're the foundation?
So you're the foundation of her life?
Right.
What?
There's no one I can rely on.
Ducky, thanks for the gift!
Andricos, thanks for the 10 gifts!
Yes, there's no one else I can turn to.
That's unbelievable.
I admire you for doing that.
What?
It's not amazing.
Just living.
It's not unbelievable.
I just live.
Just the two of us.
Aito, do you want to drink a little more?
Do you want to drink a little more?
If you do, I'll prepare it for you.
Um, I think the vibes have been...
Ruby, thank you for the five gifted!
See ya!
See you later!
Bye bye!
Thanks for everything.
Oh, they don't see me out the door because I didn't spend enough money.
Okay, Nin-chan!
Nin-chan!
I feel bad now, though.
Don't worry about it.
Drink to forget.
We're just...
We're just getting rich, baby!
Yeah!
Oh, man.
I'm gonna buy her a good bottle.
I'm gonna buy her the bottle.
Get me, um...
Give me a special highball.
Of course.
Let's get her the big shampoo.
Um, so if I get this really expensive one, is her skirt just gonna fly off?
Is it just gonna go...
Is it gonna, like, tear into a thousand pieces?
She's gonna be like, Yaha!
And I'm just like, Oh, ho, ho!
This is what money can buy!
You know?
I wonder.
I'm gonna get her...
Easy to get drug from it.
Really?
Yay!
Shh, shh, shh.
Okay.
Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh.
Whoa!
Today there's...
There's zebras.
Zebra print!
I didn't expect the zebra print.
Ah, here's...
Dozo.
Yeah, she liked it.
I'm so happy about this.
Do you have any siblings?
Hai-chan?
Nope.
I'm an only child.
What did you say to her?
Why is she suddenly asking about if I have siblings, huh?
After I talked to you yesterday, Miuka, about...
About that you're a sibling.
Huh?
What did you say...
What did you tell her?
You kind of give off an older brother vibe.
So I thought you must have a little brother or sister.
As for me...
Oh yeah, I mentioned it earlier.
Back when we were talking about blood types.
Wait, what did she...
What did she say?
Oh!
They're...
They're A-type!
Do you remember Hai-chan?
I'll be impressed if you remember my family member's blood types.
Um...
Younger brother...
And younger sister...
Are both...
A.
Yeah!
Wow,
you like actually remembered?
What should I do?
How about a kiss on the cheek as a reward?
Good.
I have a little brother and sister who are way younger than me.
They're both super cute.
When I go back to my parents' house, they call me Onee-chan, Onee-chan.
They come and stick their feet into my door.
And they're super cute, right?
Super cute!
Whenever I visit my parents, they cling to me and call me Big sis!
Big sis!
They literally wrap themselves around my legs.
Totes adorbs!
I'm so cute!
Don't diagnose me, you guys!
We are so in.
Oh my god, she's getting everything- Oh my god, guys, she's talking about her family.
This is basically like meeting her family.
You know?
She's so- We're already on that level.
Oh my gosh.
Are you so reliable because you are an older sister, Nin-chan?
jijroo It was suspicious of her without makeup.
And her mother was back home.
It was ridiculous.
It's like my younger sister, важ eu thang ajiez ikko You think I'm reliable?
Yeh.
Really?
That's how you think of me?
I think I'm blushing.
But compared to me, Miyuka is definitely more of a reliable big sister.
Miyuka, one of the cast members here?
Yeah, we're like basically married.
Oh my gosh.
I'm...
I'm... but you... children!
She also has a much younger sister, but they live together.
She looks after her too.
She's amazing!
I mean, don't... I don't mean to compare us, but there's a lot of things I'm not so reliable at.
You know?
Like I spoil my younger siblings way too much.
I buy toys and stuff for them.
All the time.
We have a wife.
I'm so proud of us, you guys!
I'm so proud of us!
We're gonna grow old with Nin-chan!
I'm gonna be like that guy that married Hatsune Miku.
Just gonna put Nin-chan on an iPad.
Talking about them is making me miss them!
I'll call when I go home.
Oh, they'll be asleep in the morning then.
Hatsune Miku, don't you have enough to drink?
I still have a lot of things to prepare...
Oh, that's... extend!
What do you drink?
I guess it doesn't really matter what I buy.
Let's get some fine wine.
What do you like?
What's your favorite thing?
Is it this young man?
I don't know.
Don't forget the present.
I already gave it to her.
I want... I'm gonna get the bunny punch since...
I mean, I could get...
The lab parry.
Everyone loves the yo man.
Oh my god, I almost accidentally pressed decision on this one.
Oh...
She likes the champagne a lot.
Yeah...
Look at her staring at me.
So patiently waiting for me to make a decision.
See if it'll let you get...
No, I don't have enough money.
I don't have enough money for the yo man.
You know what?
Go big or go home.
Seriously?
Yay!
I'll go get the bottle.
We're getting paid soon anyway.
So whatever.
It doesn't matter.
Itadakimasu.
Okay.
Oh, yes.
Oh, I can't give her any...
Okay, yeah.
Hai-chan.
Can you draw?
Illustrations?
Oh, can you draw at all?
Like illustrations?
Not very well.
Why do you ask?
I'll do the original, so you can draw.
We'll both become manga artists.
Isn't that great?
Oh!
I'll write the story and you can do the drawings.
Let's become a manga author tag team.
What do you say?
Can you write, Rin-chan?
A long time ago...
There was a father and a mother in a certain place.
Oh.
Once upon a time in a certain land, there was a father...
I mean a mother and a father.
That sounds like the opening to a folktale.
Doesn't that sound more like a picture book than a manga?
A manga author?
That might be a good thing.
My younger brother and younger sister will be happy.
A picture book author, huh?
That could work, too.
It'd make my little brother and sister really happy.
Every time she sticks her finger up like that, it makes me just want to talk like a nerd.
But...
I can't think of anything else.
I guess I can't.
It's impossible.
I've been longing for creative activities.
That's like the very beginning of the story.
But I can't come up with anything past that.
I guess I'm just not cut out for it.
I wish I was more creative.
When you read manga, don't you want to write something fun like this?
When you read manga and stuff, do you ever think, Man, I wish I could write something this good?
Hmm.
I did when I was a kid.
I wanted to be a manga author or a film director.
Same.
I can't help but envy people like that.
I wonder if I can write something, too.
Maybe if it's a game genre I'm good at.
Hai-chan, can you draw sexy girls?
Sorry.
But I don't think I can draw much of anything at all.
Maybe I should use you as a reference.
Then I could get better at...
Come on, Haito.
Say it.
Hai-chan, what do you want to drink?
Do you want to drink a little more?
Let's get something ready.
Let's get something else to drink.
You did it!
You were about to get a little lonely.
I... I...
I'm starting to actually get a bit of a...
headache.
So this might be my last day.
But I'm so sad!
I wanted to get more stuff.
I wanted to unlock the...
the...
the vacations.
But...
Next time, maybe.
So let's get to the end of this night.
Let's drink...
I'm gonna have a simple beer.
I'm a simple man.
And I'll get you...
What did she like?
I like, uh, the highball.
Uh, the umeshu.
I like seeing just the tiny bit of cheeks, right?
It's kinda cute.
Hai-chan, are you hiding something from me?
No, I don't think so.
Why do you ask?
Are you trying to hide something from me?
Aren't you just choosing things out of our hearts?
That's not what I like to do.
Draw me like you're French girl's mint.
When I get married, shouldn't you be more difficult with your people?
Not a problem.
Don't you find it hard to keep secrets like that?
What did I do?
I'm no good at it.
Don't you think I'm also a stupid?
People tell me that my face makes it super obvious.
My friends and family have planned a surprise party or something, but it hasn't worked out.
I've tried planning surprise parties for friends and family members, but it's never worked.
They always figure it out.
She knows I'm a Vtuber.
She knows that I'm streaming this.
Are you good at keeping secrets, Hai-chan?
I have nothing to hide.
Oh my god, we got a good reaction out of her.
You can't be serious.
Nothing at all?
You just lay everything out bare, huh?
That's amazing.
I lay it all out, everybody.
I'm not good at keeping secrets.
But I also usually can't tell if someone is hiding something from me.
You mean you don't notice when someone lies to you?
The wool has been pulled over my eyes more than a few times.
It sucks.
She's so cute.
Like, what the heck?
When I try to lie, they figure it out right away.
It's not fair.
This whole world is so unfair.
She has toggles.
It's a lie, right?
Well, I don't really like people who lie a lot anyway.
I much prefer honest people like you, Rin-chan.
If you say so, then I guess it's fine.
Oh, it's getting late.
Go home.
Holy moly.
I am broke.
This checks out.
You started the game telling everyone you just got fired.
That's so true.
Come again.
I'll be waiting.
Thank you for today.
Energy.
Motivation.
Money.
Oh my gosh.
It's already June.
Nice.
We didn't even lose that much money.
Saves come from the big bottle.
Yeah, we'll have to get the big bottle.
Actually, let's do gambling one more time.
Gamble, gamble.
Come on, guys.
Come on.
Pray, pray, pray.
Pray for us.
Pray.
What?
You guys prayed.
This is because of you.
What's the most that you guys have seen someone win in the gambling?
What's the most you've seen that someone has won?
That was awesome.
Hahaha.
Yippee.
Didn't know you were playing this game.
I'll have to watch the archive.
Yeah.
It's been fun.
It's been a lot of fun.
40K.
Wow.
Good night.
I got 26K earlier.
70K?
No way.
125K?
Are you lying?
I'm not lying.
What happens if you...
Oh, I guess if you go broke, you have to work...
You have to do the dispatch and sleep, right?
Your overworked body.
No, we've been playing it safe, though.
So...
Maybe we got to go bigger on the gifts, right?
Maybe I got to get the luxury bag so that she'll love me and let me take pictures of her.
I don't know.
But...
We'll figure it out next time.
How long is this game, I wonder?
I'm so...
I feel like there's so much that I haven't seen yet.
But we'll play it next time.
Yes, yes, yes.
Go big or go home.
Everyone, sorry for leaving a little bit early.
My head is starting to become pain.
So, I'm going to go to sleep.
Tomorrow.
What am I doing tomorrow?
Tomorrow, I am...
Thank you!
Rabbit House from Gucci Uso is much different than I remember.
Thanks for the stream.
Also, 200k soon.
Soon, maybe.
We'll see, we'll see.
Actually, I noticed that, like, so many of my followers on Twitter...
Like, I lost so many followers.
It was like...
It's like 10,000.
I was wondering.
I was like, oh my gosh, did I get canceled or something?
Why is it...
Why?
But I guess maybe it's bots.
Oh, tomorrow I'm doing mahjong.
Yeah.
Mahjong tomorrow.
So, I'll do my best.
Hopefully, my brain won't be too empty.
But...
We shall see.
But I want blue archive.
So...
Otsuminto.
Mint canceled.
And maybe it's bots.
I don't know.
But I noticed this morning.
I was like, whoa.
Because I saw that I was at like 144.
And then now I'm at like 135.
So, it's like crazy.
They discovered you smell.
No.
I have to think of something to do for 200K though.
I didn't think of anything for 100K.
So, I have to think of something really good for 200K.
But I think I still have a little bit of time to think of something.
So...
I'll try.
Think of something.
Anyway.
I'm gonna go to bed now.
Otsuminto.
You ego searching, huh?
Oh, yeah.
Going to my own profile is totally ego searching.
Yes, thank you.
Gosh.
Actually, you can't even ego search my name.
Because you know what?
If you search mint, all you get is a bunch of cryptocurrency.
So, I can't even ego search me.
All you get is crypto.
It's impossible.
Okay.
Otsumito.
Bye-bye.
See you later.
See you tomorrow.
Bye-bye.